vendo tutti ragazzi breve non è solo io
sono fa vj e se non vi ho assorbito le
orecchie non sono più capaci a fare la
mia intropia o tornati su super calais
magi dovermi equa supercar e magix 0 il
gioco vi sia questa la copertina
dell'ultimo video verrà fatta sia nel
caso non si fosse capito grazie se io
che mi fai pure le copertine se vuoi
montarmi anche i video
siamo a posto ma ciancio le bande
ripartiamo da dove eravamo rimasti
super che il magistero della gen dop del
caricare sono bellissimi ok ci sia o
ragazzi lavori massi in questo preciso
punto mi sono dovuto rifare tutto per
arrivare qua perché il mio dio non cos'è
sta roba qua ho tratto un gamba
la gente quanto quanto è forte la gente
il 7 il 7 fortissimo e tipo come la
banana
no ragazzi forse anche più forte
comunque ragazzino ho notato che la
gente che sa in questa precisa zona è
veramente difficilissima da buttar
aggiungiamo una vita incredibile carota
pecca della carota niente e non c'ho
mira questa roba qua teoricamente
dovrebbe sciogliere il ghiaccio può
essere sì perché fuoco teoricamente non
riuscire a passare nel punto di prima
spiega
[Musica]
stavo scherzando mi sono fatto distrarre
da da questo che un meccanismo che non
sa che cosa farà
io non schiaccio più niente in questo
gioco ve lo assicuro 321 legge niente
memorie basta mamma mia che fastidio
ce lo fa una vita e mezza beffa sta roba
cosa c'è siliqua dentro non c'è donald
trump me ne vado si sta roba qua ho
trovato un sacco di tu sei una leggenda
grazie tipo strava appunto salve
biscotto il professore è l'uni provvisto
biscotto mi manda kiko dell'accademia
sono venute a salvarla non è ancora
morto vero dio morto
no ma c'è mancato poco che non morissi
di visitazione perché si è dimenticato
di bere mentre scrivevo il diario era
andato un attimo al sotterraneo per
cercare un libro sulle crostate devo
essermi perso per fortuna mi ha fatto
scoprire questo passaggio segreto
conveniente qui a fianco a lei sgrò
ragazzi quindi abbiamo tanto il dottor
biscotto andiamo nel passaggio segreto
che i co.co.co spiego che in tutto quel
casino era causato dai cane magico esso
però viveva in una fortezza
impenetrabile con una fragola sopra
infatti davanti alla fortezza c'era una
barriera di cioccolato che era
impossibile da superare gli unici che
avrebbero la forza di studio sono i sei
maghi e maghe i docenti pop art se
misteriosamente spariti
essi sono la maga ciambella insegnanti
di trasfigurazione degli zuccheri
il mago biscotto professore di storia
della pasticceria la maga lecca lecca
maestra di pozioni buone da bere che bel
naso il mago soso highlight di difesa
contro i dolcificanti il vago panino con
la marmellata che insegnava agli
studenti a fare il verso del pesce e il
mago spaventapasseri
un tizio di trovare i maghi o non
riusciremo mai a passare la barriera di
cioccolato ho tirato fuori dall'armadio
i loro cani cioè i loro bastoni cioè i
cani magici che però sono in realtà dei
bastoni
lo scopo del gioco quindi si è scoperto
che trovare i professori questa per un
segreto si dottor biscotto con la magia
esiste ma è impossibile e invece è
possibile a ok esiste e funziona per
tutti i muffin cosa pensi che alimenta
il tuo cellulare
per me lo sono sempre chiesto il
complice compli fanta mentazione ora sai
che la magia esiste davvero ma devi
scegliere a quale tipo credere
dall'interfaccia delle credenze per
sbloccare i poteri ha poi sospeso per
sbloccarmi talenti acqua uno degli
elementi più sfuggenti dell'universo la
cane manzia va bene salve signor i cani
di nemi dove sono i vostri padroni robot
ogg
senza rincorsa impossibile localizzare
mango silent nello spazio temporale al
locale rumori di computer ho capito ma
ditemi dove sono ho trovato un tunnel
che non so dove mi porta però contando
fino a capire se seguiranno questo gioco
su youtube clicca mi piace subito che
ragazzi lo dice questa tizia dovete
studiare vi piace dove che sono finito
sono entrati in una caverna
completamente a caso ex ispettrice sofia
e ti tengo d'occhio vediamo come te la
cavi con questi scagnozzi delle verdure
mandare di senso dove che esattamente
sto andando qualcuno uno schema io sto
andando in sono entrato in una porta a
casa completamente h cos'è sta roba
siete voi l'esploratrice misteriosa e
ain el pollo
io no hai per caso visto quel che stregò
margot da queste parti
proprio no a nordovest di doversi
trovare la foresta a caso mi fa le posto
che una strega vorrebbe visitare e anche
dove viverne patate un posto per i così
intricato va bene
non ho i salami per comprarla perché
così si comprano con i salami in questo
gioco
ho trovato questo che non ho capito bene
a cosa serve però me lo tengo
ecco ecco la prima prima porta apri
veloce veloce che un casino ok se dovete
vado di qui i ragazzi non solo sto
andando la vab e non fa niente o
attenzione foresta a caso l'ho trovata
ragazzi qua dentro perché prende un po
di di pollo e salsiccia occhio mannaia
dopo una portata a caso al pomodoro
bet.com aveva tolto la foresta a caso
non so quale dei maghi sta andando a
cercare in realtà però vabbè
chissenefrega
non me lo ricordo non ho prestato
attenzione o non ho capito c'è una
curiosa filastrocca scritta su questa
stele la strada centrale e spesso la
migliore al tempio del carciofo vai ad
ovest dopo la pioggia celeste e forse
qualche tipo in indizio tanto sono che a
questo punto che mi sa che ci posso
viaggiare veloce vero posso tornare
veloce velocissimo che bello però va
bene così rim animali qua e là prevede
come era come sono sono un pro gamer di
questo gioco regala io non temo che male
devo trovare qualcosa ragazzi fra i
robusti perché mi fanno malissimo i
libici c'è sicuramente un oggetto per
documentarmi la difesa
wright cosa ho attivato non ho capito
cosa cavalca occhio da qualche i danni
li prendo solo io mi famiglia che male
aprite che sfiga se devo fare per farmi
aprire secolo ammazzare tutti può essere
aiuto quando c'è tanta gente quest'arma
che cioè incredibile
mamma mia che botta c'è la pizza morto
imparato a giocare vedo può essere molto
20 volte penso di sì perfetto sono anche
salito di livello voglio fare fuori un
boss raga mi sento di boss battle
come non detto salve lei è gregorio chi
chiede perché hai appaga gorio
ma la smetta ma cosa fa gregorio ma
porca vacca attaccato gregorio beccate
questo che male è mosso mari e comunque
ecco infatti sui singoli i nemici sono
molto svantaggiato però sui tanti faccio
la mia mamma è morto gregorio potrà
tornar ma potrete 2 frizzante l'abside
dello spam e quanta roba questa che non
velo e viola addirittura questa più miti
mano incredibile
[Musica]
il cappello del cane mi dà molto più
mara quindi prendo questo ragazzi che mi
gusto bild ma neanche in dark souls
giusto equipaggiamento sono ancora nella
foresta a caso ragazzi come cucinare una
pasta litio da diventati bravissimi a
cucinare ora sapete di cucinare la pasta
litio da grazie sì io non saprei come
fare senza rieccoci una banale io
stavano ancora non l'ho capita così una
specie di lanterna cos'è
spiegami non mi attaccare avventuriero
rustico basta a questa missione troppo
difficile continua a girare in tondo
cerca di raggiungere patata cavalier
mucca né gli ha detto che da qualche
parte il cellulare ma cos'è ma io non so
di cosa sia una stele la stele questa
cosa aspetta la trovo io
salve cestaro è un'altra meteora che
cascata qua
ok go aspetta questa questo è il mio e
in teoria dovrebbe essere posto mio
se devo fare qua c'è una scritta
rovinata su questa stella eccola la
strada a punto i butini e spesso puntini
puntini al tempio vai ad pioggia est
non ho capito niente oh mio dio no vi
prego e gioco cavità o poca vita
attenzione maio o poco vinta bastata
trio quando fischio la gente sorride
loquace vampirismo quindi mi ridà un po
di vita poca ma me la vita ok
io e te lancio direttamente al tuo amico
grande la banana
sono salito di livello mi ha ridato
tutta la vita quando succede sta roba
nei giochi e fantastico ci dovremmo
essere 3 2 1
mammamia lorenzo complimenti brown
ottima mira che c'è di qua la strada che
mi sia giusto a due vie e non lo so come
a sinistra mannaia quanto in un gusto
percorso un calcio secolo al tempio del
carciofo vai ad ovest e dopo la pioggia
ad est quello già scritto tempio del
carciofo ove è qua mi sa che devo andare
ad est giusto quindi completamente a
destra no aspetto sbagliato non nemico
sbagliato era al centro e poi a destra
ci riproveremo in un altro video ragazzi
ho sbagliato a interpretare il messaggio
della stele perché non so distinguere la
destra dalla sinistra dal centro prova
bene però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi io
concludo quale di soldi e di supercane
magik 02 02 questa è la copertina di
visto sfruttando al massimo grazie si
osservi disegnato così bello mi vedrete
così probabilmente in qualche vignetta
quindi spera ve ne sia piaciuto
accorgersene proposito mi piace anche
per i seguivo dove schizzare se non so
che ci siete vi e noi come sempre ci
vediamo a propulsione bene
[Musica]